when you come to bed after a long day of
work and you try to sit
and read a book do you find your mind
drifting
do you find that you can't even keep
your eyes open for five minutes to read
hi you are watching my youtube channel
what i'm trying to say is that there are
specific reasons why it's becoming
harder to read
now this isn't universal this isn't the
same for everybody but i do feel like
there
is increasing alienation from the
process
of focused reading especially fiction
reading
here's three ways capitalism is ruining
reading the way we consume entertainment
is kind of constantly changing we live
in an attention economy everything is
seeking to grab our eyes when you log
into youtube the youtube algorithm's
only motivation is to keep you watching
the second we pick up our phone
a million different apps are sending us
notifications
a book is different a book takes
intention
which leads me to my second point it
becomes about the process of owning
books more than
the reading itself i love books as an
object
right i objectify books it's disgusting
since
there is no inherent value in in reading
there's no like monetary value we need
to
seek some kind of aesthetic value from
the object itself
the process of buying and
owning and collecting books it feels
like it's becoming
more valuable than the reading process
itself
makes more sense in this world to buy a
bunch of books
than it is to read just
by yourself and lastly i want to talk
about the inherent
uselessness of reading especially
fiction
capitalism especially at this late stage
is
encouraging consumers to
monetize to create businesses out of
everything
that we do i don't mean that literally
but it all needs to be
put to the purpose of monetary gain
i think that's why a lot of people don't
even bother with fiction
if they read a book it's going to be
non-fiction where they're gaining some
information that's going to be valuable
to their career or
is going to help them with a specific
issue that's been bothering them
or books about self-help how to improve
yourself how to become a more productive
person in society why would you feel
good
honestly why the hell would you feel
good about yourself for reading
a long fantasy book can't just enjoy it
you can't just have a [ __ ] hobby
you have to you have to figure out how
it's going to better yourself
i think everything i'm saying is pretty
obvious
these things don't just apply to reading
they apply to other
hobbies other things people enjoy but
and in a lot of ways i think
the idea of booktube i mean in some
senses it's a community
that's able to make valid people's
experiences
reading books and on the other end it's
a process
by which people who love to read can
feel more productive
god just to sit down and read you have
to stop a million moving parts
i don't know what else to say about the
subject right now so i hope you all are
having a pleasant
year so far all those resolutions
don't even worry about them